so you you didn't like the substance of
what Obama was trying to do but you at
least grant him the respect of you felt
he's doing what he thinks is right so
basically sort of getting American
influence out of a lot of things which I
think there's merit to a lot of that
because we've messed up a lot of things
although often the vacuum ends up being
a lot worse so there's right unintended
consequences I think with Obama you see
and I mean I the portrait I made of him
in 2012 was that here's a guy who
doesn't like this notion that he is the
defender and protector of American
interests it's the adjective American
that gets him he sees himself in a more
Olympian way he's sort of above the fray
he's sort of president of the world and
he can see that this America is pushing
for some things but it's kind of his job
at times to sort of resist it he's a
global sort of balancer now that's not
what a democracy elects its leader to do
and so that's why I think there is a
sense even among his own supporters is a
slight discomfort with the way he talks
he D he speaks a language that appears
different from traditional Americana and
by traditional Americana I mean the
language that John Kerry would be
comfortable with do congas Jimmy Carter
certainly Truman FDR Obama doesn't speak
that language do you think there's more
of a desire these days I think in the
world their sense seems to be desired
that we want to become this globalized
civilization now that's obviously that's
what you're saying he sort of wants
right that he doesn't want us sort of
above anybody but we if we're all sort
of equal playing field then things are a
little bit different I assume you're not
you're not into the idea of globalism in
that regard well I mean I you know I
love the fact Reagan what's the fear I
guess is my question if if his ambitions
had become right in the United States
and sort of pulled back from certain
things and not done as much
internationally what ultimately do you
think the fear is for you well the fear
for me is that I think Obama thinks that
the United States for example let's take
something like energy we have 5% of the
world's population but we actually use
20 to 25% of the world's energy
resources we use 4 to 5
time's our share now the truth of it is
we mind a lot of that energy we buy the
rest of it we're not stealing anybody's
energy so to me there's nothing wrong
with the fact that we use more or the
fact that we have a higher standard of
living we produce more America's a
richer country were very successful
economy so to assume that American
affluence is the product of some global
oppression is monotonous we didn't take
it from anybody we didn't rob anybody
even in places like Iraq where we
supposedly invade we spend more money
over there than and then we get out of
it now if we had been real imperialists
we'd go to the Iraqis and go listen
we're gonna be billing you weekly for
all our expenses over here and taking it
out of your oil revenues we're all going
to be paying for this not up now
ironically is in that Trump's position
dramatizing his position been basically
we should be getting their oil we're not
taking the offer so that's really
interesting because he's on one hand is
running as I'm not a neocon in any way
I'm I was against this war and all this
stuff and at the same time you're
arguing that what he's really saying is
that we should be taking well as long as
we're there we long as we learn more you
must almost think that Trump wants to be
the CEO of corporation USA now if you're
a head of corporation USA you don't give
other corporations brakes right you
might stay out of this trade war do this
stuff but if you get in it you're in it
for you and you fight for your team yeah
so Trump is using that language of
nationalism now different than Reagan
Reagan was actually a cosmopolitan
different than a globalist a
cosmopolitan is a guy who goes I like
America but I also like the world Reagan
is very comfortable with European
leaders he like French food he got along
with me tear on he got along with Matt
Margaret Thatcher
he loved like Valenza from Poland yeah
so while Trump would to me seem less
comfortable in those me lose Reagan
wasn't and that's I identify with that
Reagan I'd cosmopolitanism if it were me
the world would be a place of competing
societies all prospering all trading
with each other finding no reason to
fight and lots of reasons to mutually
benefit from trade I think this this
would be a create a global engine of
prosperity yeah and I would even have
liberal immigration I mean I would have
rules so you can't just walk in the door
but we let it
illegal immigrants a year I would just
be a little more choosy about who we let
in so we get in bringing immigrants who
help America right which that's pretty
much what Trump is saying he's doing
saying it in a more bombastic way but
that's basically he's saying people can
come in but they have to do it legal
right whether we trust I mean my issue
is that I just don't know that I have
any reason to trust our authorities that
are doing this that not not trust their
intentions but trust their
qualifications and their training to
know that we can let in the right people
well terrorism has changed the game a
little bit because now we have this we
have to have this elaborate vetting
process in the past it was simply a
matter of what do we want more doctors
we want more maids do we need more
agricultural workers it was kind of a
simple you know what does the country
need financially but now it's also
become you know how do you create a net
so that the few bad guys that are gonna
try to sneak past and get blocked and
that's not easy to do yeah so what in
terms of the immigration thing I mean
what would you say because to me it's a
two-prong thing it's there's a cultural
problem and there's a religious problem
I see those things and those things I
think are intertwined at many levels but
where do you think we should be let I
mean a town I don't know how many people
were letting in right now what we learn
about a million legally but we let an
unknown number Illya the Islamic problem
the trumpet's talked about is you know
that and that the problem with the
Islamic population is out of a billion
Muslims um you have a fairly large
number that a sympathetic to radical
Islam this is based on the pude studies
in the world value survey also known as
gross and racist depending on who you're
talking to
okay we're not saying that these are all
terrorists but we're saying that these
are people who if you said Hamas they
smile no Hezbollah yeah they like it and
this population could be twenty five to
thirty percent of the billion people so
that's 250 million people now you know
that this is not the same as any other
group I mean you just can't find that
many Buddhists or Hindus or anyone else
that shows so so there's something toxic
about what's going on in the Islamic
world today again I don't think it's due
to Mohammed or the Quran it's due to
something that's happened politically in
the last 50 years but here it is and
it's a reality and so the truth of it is
you're you're much more likely to have
problems from a terrorist point of view
the Muslim population than you are with
anyone else just a matter of the odds
and the question is how do we deal with
that so I would argue that the if you
were to look at three books anyone that
took any you know that's a big three
monotheistic books that anyone that took
any of these books literally there is a
tremendous amount of violence in all of
them but you have to look at the
ideology because only one of those big
three religions right now is acting out
on it so I don't mind what the books say
because most people think their
metaphors or allegories or whatever but
if one part one group is looking you
knows one subset of one group just to be
to be fair is use is acting on stuff
literally then that's the inheritance oh
I don't mind the books as much as the
people that act on them well as I
mentioned so Sherman I gonna debate the
Bible yeah so right away he's gonna come
out and start reading passages in the
Old Testament stone your kids you know
I'm this sort of thing and all this sort
of stuff adultery is punishable by death
and so on okay number one I don't think
we have good evidence that even the
ancient Hebrews stoned their kids right
you know second there was a debate in
early Christianity between the Apostles
on one side many of them and Paul on the
other about whether the Christian should
follow any of that stuff and Paul won
that debate and the Christians decided
no we don't have to follow a Jewish
dietary laws we in order to follow their
codes now we follow the Ten Commandments
but we don't have to follow all those
other rules and so this is not some 19
or 20th century innovation from the very
beginning Christianity goes we're not
doing that right so there it is in the
book and it is incorporated into the
Bible but on the other hand it's not
read as a code it's read as an
indication of how the people then lived
under those codes so I think a certain
of and I'll assume a certain amount of
sophistication has to be applied to the
Koran as well there the passages from
Mecca the passages from Medina Muhammad
said one thing when he was winning
another thing when he's losing and so
different Muslims read those passages
differently and they also in the in the
world I mean by and large I would not
feel unsafe if I walked walked
understood the Muslim streets of
Indonesia the Indonesian Muslims are by
and large round blowing people up
I would feel a lot less safe if I were
today walking let's say for example in
in Iran yeah I believe they're Muslims
in both countries but their their
historical the history is different
right now that's where everyone gets so
confused on I mean there's nationalities
there's ethnicities there's the
sunni-shia divide all of this stuff and
people want to paint everything with
such a broad brush it's kind of
ridiculous alright so we don't have a
ton of time left but I do want to hit on
the AP ISM thing a little bit
so you've debated Michael Shermer who I
who I love and you've debated David
Silverman who's also been on the show
both of them I think view their own
atheism at slightly differently than
each other which i think is interesting
what is the are these debates purely
intellectual for you or do you have a
sort of vested vested interest but some
sort of interest in actually trying to
show Michael if you're sitting across
from him no you're actually wrong on
this or is it really just the
intellectual well I mean I sort of I
sort of rediscovered my Christian faith
an adult life I was actually a very
lukewarm social type of Christian for
most of my life and I became more
interested as an adult I became
interested in it
less as an explanation of the world and
more as actually a way to make your life
better um and one day I was watching TV
and I look and I go wow there's
Christopher Hitchens whom I know I known
from DC yeah actually once debated
Hitchens on socialism in the late 80s
and there he was debating some pastor
from Birmingham and just playing the guy
and of course it was partly as the
pastor when a Divinity School it only
knows the Bible in Hitchens knows
history and philosophy and literature
and so on and so I'm like you know
that's not a fair fight so I kind of
emailed Hitchens like Oh Hitchens stop
this you know come on debate somebody
your own size kind of thing and I
offered to step in the ring with him to
which he happily took me up on it so we
started doing these debates and they
were a huge success
I couldn't keep people away and we did
ten of them ten debates and then I
debated Sam Harris and some of the other
guys as well and and I find that the
Atheist community it falls into
different camps I mean they're all very
different you get the idea from a
Richard Dawkins so the reason he's an
atheist is that he's a true scientist
and he's sort of looking for evidence
out there kind of like the Soviet
cosmonauts who would go up into space
and go okay
report from here no God ever found him
here we don't see him up here you know
that kind of thing that type of
reasoning now a guy like Shermer is more
complex because with Shermer you know
he'll tell you he'll say well you know I
used to date this girl we were in love
we were gonna get married
and then she had a paralyzing accident
and so both of us prayed to God like God
come on help us out here
you know cure her but she doesn't get
cured or she dies
mhm and he goes you know that shook my
Christian faith so this is different to
me this is not a t ism this is sort of
like wounded theism it's sort of like
God you know it's not I don't believe in
you I'm a little ticked off at you
I don't think you're running the world
very well I'm not show you all that just
see this is a more complex atheism that
Isaiah Nietzsche would have been really
interested in and it's very different
than the sort of just scientific atheism
which is that hey I don't see evidence
for a god right so I think when you're
talking about the scientific atheism
you're sort of talking about new atheism
which I don't even like that term
because to me new atheism means just
atheists who are speaking up and I keep
seeing them being attacked by the left
which makes no sense to me either
because this these should be their
natural allies who have no problem
attacking Christians constantly but new
atheists or whatever you want to call
them speak up about Islam and that
freaks out the left so we end up with
all these these strange connections I
mean I would say that for me personally
I've talked about on the show before I'm
not a believer but I don't care what
anyone believes as long as they're not
trying to chop off my head if you want
in the privacy of your own home believe
whatever you want and you're not trying
to legislate all right then I wouldn't
have a problem but would you say that
some of your some of the things that you
care about in terms of laws are framed
by that no not so much that but I think
what it is has been you know I've been
much influenced by the idea by Immanuel
Kant's idea that the compass of reason
is itself somewhat limited so take
something like life after death okay so
here is Shakespeare says death is the
undiscovered country we live we die were
flung into the world we don't quite know
where he came from we don't really know
what comes after death now if I run into
a Shermer and he goes dinesh the belief
that there's life after death is
dogmatic and irrational where's the
belief that there's no life after death
is scientific and skeptical I'm like
sure why is it
optical not to believe in life after
death
you know well he's asking you for any
standard of proof right it's like what
but does Tennessee the standard of proof
operates within experience right so for
example if I were to say hey I just saw
a guy with two heads
you'd be like ridiculous we've all seen
hundreds of people and they all have one
head is that so the chance to find a guy
with two heads but if I were to tell you
I just came back from a star 50
light-years away and over there they
have two heads
you could never contradict me you could
never say that's preposterous because
you have no idea what goes on over there
right so a post-death is like that none
of us have been there we have no idea so
no position has an automatic trump card
over any other if I were to believe in X
and you were to believe in Y neither of
us has an automatic high ground because
we can't expect what possible scientific
tests could we do to prove you right
right so so I fully get that example but
would you say that look if we if we both
died at the same moment every bit of any
shred of evidence that actually exists
would say that's that that we have you
know we're mortal bodies and we're going
to disintegrate and go into the earth
and that's that it is somewhat of a leap
of faith you're asking for something
more than reason to say that I think are
my spirits gonna go up to heaven I mean
I know that's it's a nice it's a nice
thought and I don't I by the way I don't
begrudge people those thoughts in any
way I'm not sitting here thinking that
I'm somehow holier than thou no pun
intended you know I mean I really don't
but there's some level of there's some
reason jump there right I don't think so
well I mean Socrates in things so here's
Socrates right he goes listen we know as
human beings that we are a mixture we
are a mixture of the physical and we are
a mixture of the non-physical and by the
non-physical he's not talking about
religion he's saying consider a thought
right
what is its mass what is its size you
can't think of a thought in any physical
dimension because it's not a physical
thing think of an emotion love hatred
Envy you know so he goes we know as
human beings we got physical stuff and
we got some non-physical stuff going on
in material stuff now he goes when we
die Socrates he goes it's obvious that
the physical stuff will disintegrate he
goes ah but what about the non-physical
stuff he goes
he goes I think that the non-physical
stuff will endure it will continue why
because it doesn't have the same pair a
perishable sort of the expiration date
stamped on it now to my knowledge no one
has ever refuted this argument no one
has actually proven that non-physical
stuff requires physical stuff even in
other worlds in order to endure so I
just think philosophically if we look at
the Greeks the Romans even pre
Christianity all this stuff is there to
be thought about and then the beauty of
a good liberal education as you're
exposed to it you could think about it
you realize that there are things that
you thought were obvious that are less
obvious when you reflect upon it I go
into these debates like that I never
like quote Authority sacred scripture
the Bible this is what it says yeah I
argue on the basis of reason alone
that's right well that's why I've
thoroughly enjoyed this conversation and
that's why I can enjoy having
conversation with Michael Shermer who
take the other position and that's a
beautiful thing all right well you guys
can check out Dinesh's movie Hillary's
America it's in theaters right now and
the link to the book is right down below
thanks for watching and we'll do it
again next week
you